during the course of the original anime
film ghost in the shell
director mamoru oshi asks an ambitious
question
in a world where humans can merge with
machines
he asks the viewer
what is it that makes us fundamentally
human
it's a beautiful film with a sprawling
world that as cliche as this sounds
really makes you think
hollywood's 100 million dollar remake
falls far short of the original concept
it also completely bombed at the box
office losing at least 60 million
dollars the ghost in the shell remake is
not alone
virtually every hollywood anime
adaptation is critically panned and
doesn't make any money
why
well for the most part they're just not
good
justin cevakis is a writer for anime
news network he believes it's the
practical differences between film and
anime that lend a hand to hollywood's
flops
when we see an animated character we're
never thinking about the after we're
never thinking about the day on the set
we very much lose ourselves in that
fantasy world so a lot of things that
are really fanciful and interesting in
animation
just don't work in live action they're
just kind of dumb looking
the dragon ball franchise is a great
example it first aired in 1986 and
follows the adventures of a human-like
alien child who protects earth by
fighting otherworldly enemies as the
series continues the battle scenes
become epic as the characters fire rays
of energy at each other as you can
imagine this is absolutely cringe-worthy
in hollywood's 2009 adaptation
[Applause]
oh my god
so why are comic book movies so
successful given that they also feature
characters with super powers and
ambitious fight scenes it has to do with
the source material adaptations of the
existing comic book is very freewheeling
they don't have to change
where it takes place because it's
already in a western land with tropes
that are already familiar to filmmakers
uh there's a lot of shared visual
language between american comic books
and movies because they've influenced
each other greatly over the decades
our favorite superheroes exist in cities
we live in
when some evil force threatens new york
city for example that means something to
american audiences
in that sense comic book adaptations
already have a leg up on anime
adaptations i think a lot of times
filmmakers go into an anime adaptation
without really fully understanding what
made the anime or its original manga
compelling in the first place
netflix's adaptation of death note is an
example of this in the original anime
series the main character light stumbles
upon a supernatural notebook if you
write someone's name in that book that
person then dies okay we now have
confirmation the suspect has been found
dead inside i repeat the suspect is now
dead dead
light feels like a judge and goes on to
kill hundreds taking up a pseudonym kira
so no one knows who he is or how he
kills there are a plethora of rules
though for instance you have to write
how the person dies within 40 seconds
otherwise they'll just die of a heart
attack the many rules for the book and
how they complicate things as part of
why people loved the series but the
netflix adaptation foregoes all of this
is that what we're gonna do with the
note light rules and warnings
the adaptation also fails to understand
why viewers of the original series loved
the characters specifically
in the anime light is a smart kid from a
nice supportive family
that's what makes his choice to become
death sentencers so interesting
in the adaptation though light's mom is
killed by people who get away with it
making his motive to kill people much
more obvious and straightforward it's
indicative of how complex ideas are lost
in translation when being adapted
obviously a lot is going to be lost
because what the original filmmaker
wanted to say uh example uh mammoth
ocean ghost in the shell was not going
to be replicated by a director making a
ghost initial film that was not the same
movie let's look at a specific scene
from the anime police are pursuing a man
who steals and destroys people's
memories
at the end of the conflict they realize
the man is part machine and had been
programmed to commit these crimes
so there was this great emotional moment
at the end of that fight scene where
you're like oh there was nothing
nothing behind that he he's just kind of
this poor lost soul
that has been programmed to be this you
know this foot soldier and now he's just
kind of this empty shell
lost and without purpose and that was
really haunting
this scene is recreated in the 2017
remake and while it succeeds in its
visual cues to the original it serves no
greater purpose to the story it's just a
fight scene
in general the remake is streamlined
into a simple story about the
protagonist's quest for her memories
losing the deeper meaning of the
original story for better anime
adaptations hollywood needs to do two
things
first they need to do a much better job
at figuring out exactly which anime is
going to translate well into live action
once they do that they need to be sure
of why fans like the anime in the first
place
for a genre of animation chock full of
amazing stories and beautifully complex
ideas this really shouldn't be that hard
for hollywood studios to figure out